mark I believe you said that every
director must also be a writer so does
that mean that every director should
rewrite in some sense the screenplay of
the movie that they're directing what a
great question goodbye do a to question
you always hit me with two questions
first of all every director I'm going to
do every director should be about it yes
every director should write whether they
write well or not is not important I
think every directors should understand
the writing process that's why we do
write your life but also the screen
writing process which is different but
and to at least understand and
appreciate the challenges I'm trying to
get a story into what I call you know
the two-hour haiku you know it's like
reducing it down to the story to those
islands and we can talk about that later
but in terms of the director rewriting
no rewriting the script addressed gets a
script it's not the director's job to
rewrite and is the director's job to
work with the writer I'm a very
passionate protector of the writer and I
think if the writer has brought a script
to a point where a director is
interested in doing it then they should
keep working with the writer I don't
understand that's getting rid of writers
are bringing in other people to rewrite
I do understand the collaboration of a
director and writer working together and
then eventually with the actors and
everybody else staying involved when
I've done films the lighter stays all
the way through the whole making of the
film all the way through production and
post-production they are part of the
storytelling team I have my job they
have their job I like having the writer
on the set i'm shooting something it was
a one film i was doing which we're
having trouble with a scene i remember
this the two writers are there is a
fighting team and we couldn't get it to
work and i told i said i'm going to
improvise the scene hold on they went
okay and i went back to the actors and i
took them through a process quick
process and then we said improvise the
scene and remember what is going yes you
got it
no the fact that the writers said yes
that's where we're going I felt great it
wasn't me rewriting the sea it wasn't
even the actors rewriting the scene the
the writers were there I'm trying to
serve their initial vision of the film
combined with mine combined with the
actors of trying to reach the characters
so I don't I don't like the idea
although it happens a lot in Europe
which you may know and I've run I have a
lot of friends because I teach a lot in
Europe especially in Germany and a lot
of friends who were very very successful
lighters there and it's a constant
problem they will write a script safe a
television that director comes on in the
director doesn't rewrite the first thing
they do is they rewrite it I was at at
one point I've directed a little bit in
Germany and I was one point was going to
direct something and the production
company said sent me the script I said
ok they said when are we going to get
your directors script and I said what do
you mean I'm reading the scripts and yes
I want to do this when you run it so
what do you lead the directors good what
they meant was we expect you to rewrite
it now so this was the producers
expecting the director to rewrite the
script that they had bought and they
wanted to produce and I said no I'm not
going to rewrite it I'm going to work
with the writer so I don't encourage
directors to think they have to rewrite
it I've seen too many times especially
in Europe directors rewriting and
reworking a script and it was really
clear what they were doing unconsciously
I think or maybe consciously they were
creating a script that they knew how to
direct and by doing that they reduced it
or shifted it from the initial intention
rather than trying to serve the script
that was there initially they altered it
to something that they could handle and
then the story lost is essence becomes a
lawsuit okay lost this is what is one
very important
project which definite mine had written
and she had a powerful script and it was
changed so dramatically into the style
of film that the director felt
comfortable in doing he had been hired
to do a film that he wasn't really
comfortable with so he changed it into
something and it changed totally had
lost to me the essence of what was there
originally it turned out flying at the
end but it was a whole different it's a
different story it wasn't what was there
originally
you